méconnu est souvent tabou la santé
sexuelle est mise en lumière le 4
septembre lors de sa journée mondiale
j'ai quoi comme choix de contraception
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé la
définit comme un état de bien-être
physique mental et social associé à la
sexualité un vaste domaine lié à
l'aspect sanitaire au respect entre
partenaires ou à la procréation dans le
département des Yvelines différents
organismes existent pour se renseigner
se faire dépister ou recevoir des
traitements en toute confidentialité et
gratuitement nez d'un mouvement
féministe il y a 60 ans l'association
planning familial offre un espace de
discussion au public et informe sur la
santé sexuelle contraception avortement
orientation ou encore violence ici au
Mureaux les conseillers reçoivent les
bénéficiaires avec ou sans rendez-vous
des animations en groupe sont également
proposées l'idée c'est de pouvoir
libérer la parole grâce à des
jeux le plus souvent donc des activités
plutôt ludiques mais qui sont souvent en
fait un prétexte pour venir se
questionner sur sur notre vie affective
et sexuelle qu'on donne des informations
quand on peut les donner et puis après
les personnes font leur propre choix en
fonction de ce dont elles ont besoin
tout comme le planning familial le
centre de santé sexuelle accueille le
public pour l'informer et l'écouter
mission du Conseil départemental ce lieu
permet aussi des consultations médicales
grâce à des médecins et des sages-femmes
présents sur place accès à la
contraception dépistage et traitement
contre les infections sexuellement
transmissibles sont quelques-uns des
actes pratiqués ici à Plaisir la santé
sexuelle fait partie de la santé
générale et la sexualité est un une
partie importante du bien-être par
exemple quelqu'un qui aurait été victime
de violences sexuelles peut être amené
avoir des conduites alimentaires
troublées et voilà on peut se demander
pourquoi telle personne et sur le chemin
de l'obésité et ben oui c'est lié à la
santé sexuelle d'autres plateformes
existent pour s'informer sur ces
différents thèmes et preuve de
l'importance de la santé sexuelle dans
notre société l'OMS a lancé début 2023
une stratégie pour lutter contre la
conduite sexuelle